وقع عبد الصبور شاهين نفسه في شراك
التكفير التي نصبها لنصر حامد ابو زيد
بعدما اقام يوسف البدري ضد شاهين دعوه
حسبه لتفريقه عن زوجته عام 2000 على خلفيه
كتاب ابي ادم الذي اعتبره البعض ارتدادا
عن الاسلام
لكن تعديل قانون المرافعات انقض عبد
الصبور شاهين من الملاحقات التي خاضها
خصمه ابو زيد
الدكتور عبد الصبور
فيما يتصل بكتابك المشكله
بانهم سوف يستخدمون الحسبه ويرفعون عليك
قضايا
وهناك شامتون يقولون انك تقف الان في نفس
الموقف الذي وضعت فيه الدكتور نصر حامد
ابو زيد يوم قرات انتاجه الفكري ونفط
ترقيته وافرت الدنيا عليه
طويت صفحه النزاعات القضائيه دون ان تطوى
صفحه التكفير والتهديدات في الصحف وعلى
المنابر
ليقرر نصر البقاء في منفاه الاختياريه